Bitte schön.
Ja, guten Tag.
Guten Tag.
Ich bin der Diensthalben der Arzt auf dieser Station.
Ich möchte mit Ihnen gerne das Erstgespräch führen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Bitte schön, gerne.
Okay.
Ich werde so etwas ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer Person stellen.
Dann kommen wir auch sofort zu Ihrem Beschwerden.
Wenn Sie etwas nicht verstehen können
oder einige Fragen haben,
bitte sagen Sie mir Bescheid
oder fragen Sie nach.
Okay.
Wie heißen Sie denn?
Mein Name ist Maus, Markus Maus.
Markus mit K oder C?
Mit K.
Mit K, okay. Vielen Dank Herr Maus.
Wie alt sind Sie, Herr Maus?
Ich bin 42 Jahre alt.
42 haben Sie gesagt?
Genau.
Okay. Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,70 m groß.
Ich bin 42 Jahre alt.
1,70 m.
Und wissen Sie, wie viel Sie wiegen?
Ungefähr 100 kg.
100 kg.
Vielen Dank für die Informationen.
Herr Maus, was für Sie heute sonst?
Wie kann ich Ihnen helfen?
Ich habe seit drei Tagen Bauchschmerzen,
die nicht weggehen.
Ich habe schon Medikamente genommen,
aber es geht irgendwie nicht weg.
Es kommt und geht.
Aber das stirbt mich so sehr stark.
Was haben Sie dagegen eingenommen?
Ich habe Überprofene eingenommen.
Kennen Sie Dosierung?
600.
600? Einmal oder mehrmals?
Ne, mehrmals.
Vierfünfmal.
Eingenommen.
Herr Maus, wie ich sage,
Sie sind nicht mehr auf einer Skala,
wobei von 1 bis 10,
wobei 1 Jahr leitet und 10,
Sie sind nicht mehr auf einer Skala,
wobei 1 Jahr leitet und 10
unerträglichen Skala.
Ja, ungefähr sieben.
Sieben bis acht, würde ich sagen.
Sieben bis acht.
Könnten Sie mir zeigen,
wo genau die Schmerzen sind?
Im Oberbau.
Im Oberbau in Mitte?
Ja, so Mitte, rechts, Mitte,
mithilfe.
Mitte.
Herr Maus,
jetzt möchte ich unser Geschenk
unterbrechen
und möchte ich
eine EKG bei Ihnen schreiben.
Und dann, wenn alles in Ordnung ist,
können wir unser Geschenk fortsetzen.
Und wenn,
und ich möchte auch fragen,
unser Geschenk dauert
ca. 20 Minuten.
Könnten Sie Ihre Schmerzen
bis zu Ende des Gesprächs
oder brauchen Sie
Schmerzmittel?
Ich denke, ich kann das sagen.
Ich denke, ich kann das aushalten noch.
Ich denke, ich kann das aushalten.
Okay, vielen Dank.
So, jetzt werde ich EKG schreiben
und
können wir fortsetzen.
Können wir fortsetzen?
Bitte, ja.
Okay.
Herr Markus,
Strahlendischmerzen in Andermen.
Herr Maus, der Name ist Maus.
Herr Maus,
Strahlendischmerzen in Andermen.
Ich habe das Gefühl,
dass ich manchmal auch Rückenschmerzen habe.
Aber
es ist eher der Oberbau.
Rückenschmerzen,
kann man sagen,
dass Schmerzen
guter Formige ist.
Nein.
Okay.
Könnten Sie die Schmerzen genau beschreiben?
Ehe Durkend, Brennend, Steven, Poend.
Das sind
sehr drückende Schmerzen.
Und
wenn Sie kommen,
ist sie wirklich sehr, sehr stark.
Kann man sagen,
dass die Schmerzen immer
immer noch stärker sind.
Ja, mal stärker, mal weniger.
Ah, okay.
Durkend.
Und mal stärker, mal weniger.
Okay.
Hatten Sie
für alle, die
Schmerzen beschwerten?
Eigentlich nicht, nein.
Erstmal, okay.
Haben die Schmerzen
plötzlich
oder langsam angefangen?
Ich hatte das
das erste Mal
vor vier Tagen ungefähr.
Da kamen sie plötzlich
und seitdem habe ich diese beschwerden.
Okay.
Plötzlich.
Könnten Sie
eine Auslöser merken?
Haben Sie etwas bemerkt,
dass die Schmerzen auslöst?
Wie meinen Sie das?
Ich meine,
wenn die Schmerzen auftreten sind,
ist etwas Ihnen passiert,
zum Beispiel
einige Essen etwas
ungewöhnliches
oder
dass Sie eine schwere Sache
erheben.
Das ist ein
ungewöhnliches Essen.
Ungewöhnliches Essen.
Das, was ich immer erst eigentlich.
So kann man sagen,
keine Auslöser haben Sie bemerkt.
Was meinen Sie mit Auslöser?
Ich meine,
ja,
wenn die Schmerzen zuerst
passiert ist,
haben Sie etwas ungewöhnliches gemacht.
Ja, ich meine,
wenn Sie das
haben,
haben Sie etwas ungewöhnliches gemacht.
Ja, ich meine,
wie ich gesagt habe, etwas Essen
oder
haben Sie in einem Restaurant
Kaffee gegessen,
haben Sie etwas bemerkt,
dass die Schmerzen
Lindert oder versteckt?
Ich habe gemerkt,
wenn ich etwas esse,
dann wird das etwas mehr.
Das habe ich auch bemerkt.
Okay.
Ist Ihnen über, Herr Maus?
Ja, wenn die Schmerzen kommen, ja.
Okay.
Haben Sie schon mal erbrochen?
Nein.
Okay.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Schutulgang?
Nein.
Nein, vielleicht.
Ja, Verstopfung
oder Durchfall?
Nein.
Okay.
Fühlen Sie sich viel wahr?
Fühle ich mich?
Viel viel.
Viel viel?
Okay.
Herr Maus, jetzt habe ich
Ihre Beschwerden verstanden
und ich werde mich bald um Ihre Beschwerden kümmern.
Jetzt hätte ich einige
Fragen zu Ihrem
allgemeinen
Gesundheitswahlzustand.
Wie sich Ihr Appetit
hat sich Appetit in der letzten Zeit geändert?
Nein, eigentlich gleich.
Ich habe nur Übelkeit.
Deswegen ist es ein bisschen weniger.
Okay.
Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie keine Fieber haben.
Leiden Sie unter Stufrost oder Nachschweiß?
Nein.
Okay.
Ich muss alles dökumentieren, was Sie erwähnen.
Ich bitte Sie ein bisschen warten.
Können Sie gut einschlafen
oder durchschlafen?
Nein.
Ja, es geht.
Ich habe Schmerzen.
Ich habe die Profen genommen, aber die gibt es ein bisschen.
Okay.
Vielen Dank.
Haben Sie in der letzten Zeit
ungewollt,
oder so genommen?
Ich habe die letzten Tage schon ein bisschen abgenommen.
Ich glaube so.
Aber ich bin nicht gewechselt, aber...
Wie viel Kilo kann man sagen,
abgenommen?
Ich habe mich nicht gemessen.
Ich habe mich gewogen.
Okay.
Ich habe die Augen
oder die Haut
gelblicher
Harbveränderung gehabt.
Haben Sie eine gelbere
Erhobene?
Ja, gelblicher
dass Ihre Augen gelblicher sind.
Oder...
Nein, habe ich nicht gemerkt.
Nein.
Okay.
Ja.
Leiden Sie unter Displos
und Sie haben die Augen gelblicher.
Nein.
Okay.
Ja, Hermos.
Jetzt hätte ich einige Fragen
für Sie vorgeschickt.
Leiden Sie
an irgendeinem
Jahr in Erkrankung.
Also,
ich habe die Augen gelblicher.
Seitdem Leiden Sie
an den Augen gelblicher.
Ja, vier Jahre.
Ja, ich nehme eine
Fablette morgens an.
Kennen Sie den Namen?
Am April.
Und kennen Sie die Dosierung?
5 Milligramm.
Einmal morgens nehmen Sie ein.
Ansonsten
Leiden Sie unter Erkrankung.
Ich nehme noch Medikamente
für Kollesterin ein.
Kollesterin.
Ja, ich nehme noch
Kollesterin ein.
Kollesterin.
Seit wann nehmen Sie
Medikamente?
Auch vier Jahre.
Okay.
Kennen Sie die Dosierung?
Die Atorvastatin.
40 Milligramm.
Atorvastatin.
40 Milligramm. Einmal.
Einmal abends.
Okay.
Und Sie haben die Dosierung?
Ja.
Leiden Sie andere Krankheiten?
Nein.
Okay, vielen Dank.
Würden Sie schon einmal operiert?
Nein.
Ja, Hermos, außer
Atorvastatin und bei Bedarf
Ibuprofen.
Nehmen Sie andere Medikamente,
regelmäßig oder bei Bedarf ein?
Nein.
Sind bei Ihnen allergin bekannt?
Okay.
Sind Sie voll geimpft?
Ich meine gegen Kinderkrankheiten
und auch Corona?
Ich denke schon, ja.
Also auch gegen Corona, ja.
Okay.
Sind Sie in den letzten 6 Monaten
in Land oder Ausland gereist?
Ich war nur in Holland.
Sie waren in Holland.
Wann waren Sie?
3 Wochen ungefähr.
Haben Sie da etwas Ungewöhnliches gegessen?
Nein.
Wir haben viel Tisch gegessen.
Okay.
Hermos, wie erleben Sie sich
allgemein?
Ich meine, was essen Sie?
Essen normal.
Okay, so.
Sie haben keine Unfertigkeiten?
Nicht das Wissen, nein.
Okay.
Ja, Hermos, wir sind bald fertig,
aber jetzt hätte ich einige Fragen
zu Ihren Geunheiten.
Sind Sie rauher?
Ich rauhe nicht.
Okay.
Nehmen Sie Alkohol zu sich?
Ab und zu, am Wochenende.
Was nehmen Sie zu sich?
Meistens Bier, oder so, Bier.
Ja, wie viele Flaschen die ihr hat?
Ja, nicht jedes Wochenende,
vielleicht 2, 3,
so, wenn Sie mit Freunden da sind.
2, 3 Flaschen Bier, okay.
Ungefähr.
Ansonsten nehmen Sie etwas oder nicht?
Nicht regelmäßig.
Okay.
Was nehmen Sie nicht regelmäßig?
Wein oder Pfeifen?
Ja, genau.
Das ist ein Problem.
Nehmen Sie nicht regelmäßig Wein oder Pfeifen?
Ja, genau.
Zum Beispiel oder Cocktails oder so.
Cocktails.
Okay.
Haben Sie erfahren mit Drogen?
Ja, habe ich gehabt.
Meine Jugend habe ich es gehabt.
Was haben Sie versucht?
Probiert?
Muss ich das jetzt sagen?
Ja, Hermos, einige Drogen.
Kann ich?
Ja, Herr Hermos, einige Drogen.
Kannst du bestimmte Krankheiten führen?
Deshalb habe ich gefragt.
Nehmen Sie bitte nicht.
Ich möchte es speziell beteiligen.
Dann sage ich ja oder nein.
Okay, okay.
Treiben Sie Sport?
Ich leide nicht.
Sehen Sie an meinem Körpergewicht.
Ja, okay, verstanden.
Sind Sie berufstätig, Hermos?
Ja.
Als was arbeiten Sie?
Ich habe es gemacht.
Informatik.
Ich arbeite nur am PC.
Okay, Informatik.
Haben Sie Stress bei der Arbeit?
Ja, aber ich kann damit umgehen.
Ja, Sie können umgehen.
Das galt.
Okay.
Hermos, sind Ihre Eltern noch am Leben?
Ja.
Sind Sie gesund?
Ja, die haben auch Bluthochdruck.
Die haben auch Bluthochdruck.
Die haben auch ein bisschen Zucker, glaube ich, meine Mama.
Und das übt mich halt.
Ja.
So, ihr fattet Leide an Bluthochdruck.
Und ihr mutet Leide an Bluthochdruck.
Und beide haben Bluthochdruck, beide.
Okay.
Alter Zucker?
Ich weiß nicht.
Okay.
Haben Sie Gezwister?
Ja, ich weiß nicht.
Okay.
Haben Sie Gezwister?
Ich bin Einzelkind.
Einzelkind.
Okay.
Wie ist Ihr Familienstand?
Ich bin geschieden.
Geschieden.
Seit wann sind Sie geschieden?
Seit drei Jahren.
Haben Sie jetzt ein festes Partnerin?
Nein.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ich möchte Sie mit Ihrem Beschwörden kommen.
Und einige Fragen stellen.
Leiden Sie anschmerzhaft wassalasen?
Nein.
Okay.
Müssen Sie öfter als normal wassalasen?
Nein.
Aber ich würde sagen nein.
Aber ich träge jetzt ein bisschen viel, vielleicht deswegen.
Aber ich weiß nicht.
Sie trinken ein bisschen.
Sie trinken mehr als sonst.
Okay.
Vielleicht deswegen.
Herr Maus,
meinerseits habe ich alle wichtige Informationen von Ihnen bekommen.
Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen
oder Fragen haben?
Kann ich antworten?
Ja, ich möchte wissen, was ich habe.
Das glauben Sie, wenn ich etwas habe.
Was kann das sein?
Herr Maus, wie gesagt habe ich wichtige Informationen.
Ich habe keine Fragen.
Ich möchte natürlich auch wichtige Informationen bekommen.
Aber alle Maßnahmen sind wichtig für uns.
Ich möchte jetzt Sie körperlich unterzunehmen
und einige Maßnahmen dünn.
Nachdem wir finden können wir genau beschreiben.
Ja, aber...
Ja.
Das haben Sie denn vorher?
Ja, das kann ein kann ein Blasen Stein sein.
Aber wie gesagt habe ich einige Maßnahmen dünn.
Nachdem die Maßnahmen können wir genau beschreiben.
Kein Blasen Stein, glauben Sie?
Ja.
Okay.
Kann das auch etwas Schlimmes sein?
Aber jetzt kann ich nicht sagen,
dass ich nicht etwas schlimmes sein kann.
Ich möchte natürlich auch etwas Schlimmes sein.
Ich möchte natürlich etwas schlimmes sein.
Aber jetzt kann ich nicht genau sagen...
Muss ich denn heute hier bleiben?
Ja, Sie...
Ja, ich würde einige Stunden in Kauf nehmen.
Aber nach dem Ergebnis können wir genau...
Wenn Sie untersuchen, klaren Sie denn?
Ja, wie ich gesagt habe, würde ich zuerst Sie körperlich untersuchen.
Ihr braucht abtasten und zuerst schauen, dann abtasten und verkütieren.
Dann würde ich eingeblutet abtasten und abklopfen.
Abtasten und abklopfen.
Dann würde ich Ihre Blut überprüfen.
Besonders, ein Zündungparameter, Leberwerte, Nierenwerte...
Sie nehmen bei mir Blut ab.
Ja.
Dann würde ich eine Urinabnahme überprüfen, ob es eine Entzündung gibt oder eine Blutung.
Dann würde ich eine Bauultraschall durchführen.
Ich würde Ihre Galamblasen, Ihre Nieren und Ihre Württeln...
Machen Bauultraschall.
Ja, Bauultraschall.
Okay, verstanden.
Soll ich hier warten?
Du kommst ja in die Fusion?
Ja, ich werde eine Zugang legen und einige Medikamente gegen Übelkeit nehmen.
Dann werden Sie besser fühlen.
Sie werden Medikamente gegen Übelkeit geben oder abreichen.
Okay.
Hab ich einen Kollegen oder Kollegen, die Sie fragen?
Ich habe ein paar Fragen.
Zwei Fragen, bitte.
Okay.
Maxime.
Habt ihr Zutrennen und Husten?
Nein, ich habe keinen Husten und keinen Zutrennen.
Habt ihr Herzrasen, Herzklopfen?
Auch nicht.
Sind Sie stressig?
Wie bitte?
Ich bin nicht stressig, ich bin auch nicht gestresst.
Okay, danke schön.
Darf ich fragen?
Ja, zwei Fragen.
Wie viele Löcher engen müssen, ihre Gültelschmallen?
Gar nicht, gleich.
Okay.
Wann war ihr gestern Abend?
Gestern Abend.
Danke.
Gestern Abend gehen wir zusammen ab.
Noch andere Fragen, Kollegen?
Ja, ich habe noch eine Frage.
Sind diese Schmerzen nach dem Essen oder vor dem Essen versteckt?
Ich habe dir schon gesagt, ich glaube, dass sie nach dem Essen mehr sind.
Deswegen jetzt ein bisschen weniger.
Danke schön.
Können Sie die Winde haplassen?
Nein.
Sie fragen, ob ich Blähungen habe, ob ich ein voller Gefühl habe.
Ja.
Danke.
Ich habe keine Erfärbung des Sturfs und keine dunkle Erfärbung des Windes.
Alles gleich.
Danke schön.
Ich habe noch keine Erfärbung des Sturfs und keine dunkle Erfärbung des Windes.
Alles gleich.
Nein, sehr gut.
Ich war seit ungefähr drei Monaten nicht beim Haushalts gewesen.
Es wurde noch nie einen Ultraschall bei mir gemacht.
Hat der Haushalts beim Checkup?
Oder wann war der letzte Checkup?
Kann man fragen.
Ist schon mal ein Ultraschall gemacht worden.
Das kann man fragen.
Ich denke alle Fragen gestellt, Herr Kollege.
Okay.
Könnten wir als erstes geschrieben werden?
Ein Moment bitte.
Ich teere es, wenn er sieht.
Oder...
Die Frage? Nein.
Ich habe es nicht gemerkt.
Danke.
Sauerstoßen?
Nein, kein Sauerstoßen.
Kein Sausbrennen, aber Übelkeit.
Okay, Umut.
Ja, können wir anfangen?
Ja.
Bitte schön.
Guten Tag, Herr Oberhass.
Heute habe ich einen neuen Patient aufgenommen,
den ich Ihnen vorstellen möchte.
Haben Sie kurz Zeit für mich?
Okay, der Patient heißt Markus Maus.
Herr Maus ist 42 Jahre alt, 1,70 m groß
und wiegt 100 kg.
Er hat uns wegen seit 3 Tagen bestehender,
akkut angefangener Druckende,
um die Ausstrahlung der Schmerz zu erheben.
Laut dem Patienten,
die Schmerzintensität von 7 bis 8 von 10,
hat er bis 5 Mal,
500 Milligramm Tablet,
und die Schmerzintensität von 7 bis 8,
hat er bis 5 Mal,
die Schmerzintensität von 7 bis 8,
Poli-Üre.
Polnakis-Süriere oder Poli-Üre.
Hatte ja gesagt.
Nicht gesagt.
Polidüpsi. Entschuldigen Sie, Polidüpsi.
Ich würde mehr trinken, hatte ja gesagt.
Ja, er trinkt einfach mehr, aber er hat nicht mehr Dos.
Ja, er trinkt einfach mehr, also er hat keine Polidüpsi.
Ja, okay, ja, sehr gut.
Zudem vegetativen beschwerden in Apathens, Nausea
und weniger Gewichtabnahme in den letzten Monaten bekannt.
Gewichtabnahme.
Gewichtabgenommen habe er gesagt.
Dann habe ich falsch verstanden, okay.
Ja, ich terus,
diesme, melena,
tahikardi,
wurden von der Patient verneint.
Anvor Erkrankungen leide er seit vier Jahren
an Arteriellhypertone, dagegen nehme er
am April 5-Mg Tablet, einmal Mogens ein
und er leide an Piperkollestern,
seit vier Jahren, dagegen nehme er
Atobastatin 40 mg, einmal Abends.
Vor Erkrankungen, Allergien sind
seien unbekannt bei den Patienten.
Sie haben außer die Medikamente, die ich erwähnt haben,
keine Medikamente ein.
Seien im Status vollständig, sie seien
vor drei Wochen in Holland gewesen.
Er sei kein Raul.
Mit wem?
Sie seien?
Er sei in Holland gewesen.
Ja, er sei.
Er sei kein Raul.
Und eine Kotinkonsum beträgt
zwei bis drei Flaschen Bier am Wochenende
und gelegenlich Cocktails.
Er hatte Erfahrung mit Drogen,
aber ich konnte nicht ganz
Informationen bekommen, weil er
nicht darüber sprechen möchte.
Er ist kein Sportler.
An Vaterlitz seit, gab
Gehbea Artilleripartoni ein.
Und seine Mutter leide an Artilleripartoni
und Diabetes Melitus.
Sie sei ein Zeltkind.
Er war ein Zeltkind.
Er sei seit drei Jahren genügend
und habe keine feste Partnerin
und keine Kinder.
Er arbeitet als Informatik
und habe Stress bei der Arbeit.
Laut dem Patienten
sind sie immer an Computer
und arbeiten.
Ja, die erhobenen
anestetischen Angaben
und deuten am ersten auf
eine Kolelthiasis hin.
Und als Differenzialdiagnose
kommen
Nephrolithiasis,
Magen-Ulser
und Magen-Geschwur
Neocardinfarktus,
Aote dissektion
und ja, hin, hin.
Und was? Ach so, okay.
Ja.
Was spricht denn für ein Darstrittis?
Was spricht für eine Bankriertitis?
Ja, die Schmerzen mit Astralen rücken
und Naruk aphenge Schmerzen
und nausea
übergewichtig
und risikofaktör
hyperkolesterimiastiskofaktör
sprachen für eine Bankriertitis und Kolelthiasis.
Aber ja,
ja, aber
yteformige Schmerzen
und emesis
und Schutul-Fahrtveränderung
ichterus wurden von der Patient verneint
diese sprachen gegen Bankriertitis.
Ja, und epikastische Schmerzen
mehrmals über Profeneinnahme
sprachen für eine Gastritis.
Aber er hat ja über Profenes nach den Schmerzen eingenommen.
Ja, aber er hat mehrmals über Profen,
ja, ja, sie haben Red.
Sie haben nach dem Schmerzen eingenommen.
Okay, wir bleiben bei den drei Defensiatdiagnosen.
Scholezysulatiasis,
ja, Bankriertitis.
Ja, aber
er hat ja keine Flankenschmerzen, er hat keinen Nierenkollig.
Er hat keine Flankenschmerzen,
an dem wir von Netfolatiasis sprechen normalerweise.
Ja, epikastische Schmerzen,
von drei, vier Organen betrachten.
Wir bleiben bei Scholezysulatiasis,
wir bleiben bei Bankriertitis,
Scholezysulatiasis, glaube ich nicht,
dann würde man Ictorus haben, eventuell,
wenn der Geile im Gang zu ist.
Was machen Sie jetzt im Diagnostik aktuell?
Was haben Sie vor?
Ja, zuerst würde ich den Patienten körperlich untersuchen,
Bauch palpieren
und den Bauch palpieren
und zuerst inspirieren,
ob es eine Greaterne Seife gibt.
Dann würde ich palpieren
und
ja, dann würde ich
beim Blutabnahme
alle Aset, GGT, Blubinwerte
und ein paar Meter wie CRP,
Prokastonin
und ja auch Niedermerte,
Handstoff und
Kratinin überprüfen.
Ja, auch um eine
myocardial infarctus auszuschließen,
würde ich EKG schreiben.
Troponin?
Ja, Troponin und myocrobium-Bain-Bluutabnahme
würde ich auch
überprüfen.
Okay.
Dann
Sie können eigentlich
mit einer Untersuchung ausschließen,
ob eine Schulle zu stilatieren,
das hat oder nicht, mit einer Untersuchung. Welche machen Sie?
Ja, wenn ich
meine Sie beim
präpärischen Untersuchung.
Nein.
Nein, auch nicht.
Mit einer Diagnostik.
Würde ich eine
Abdominal-Utrasphonografie führen?
Genau.
Ja, gegebenenfalls, eine
MRCP
können Sie in der Ambulanz
sofort machen, muss geplant werden,
dazu muss der Patient da bleiben.
Aber Ultraschall hört sich gut an.
Ultraschall können Sie sehen, ob er eine
Schollizistilitis hat, ob er eine Schollistase hat,
das können Sie ganz gut sehen.
Wenn Sie gut sonografieren können, können Sie auch sehen, ob eine
kein Kreativität hat oder nicht.
Das ist schwierig.
Ja, kann man nicht einfach.
Deswegen müssten Sie Labor und Ultraschall zusammen
sehen.
Gut, Sie haben gesagt,
Returnerzeichen, das ist eher für Pankratitis.
Aber Kuläne und Kuläne
Returnerzeichen,
chronische Pankratis,
und Stehe, auch bei Akutapankratitis.
Akutapankratitis.
Ja, aber
ich würde sagen, der Patient hat auch keine,
wie Sie schon richtig gesagt haben, keine
kreativiertem Ausstrahlung.
Er hat kommen,
in den
Schmerzen,
passt er entweder gastritis
oder Schollizistilitis.
Schollizistilitis
können Sie ausschließen im Ultraschall,
wenn Sie den Ultraschall machen,
ohne Schollistasewerte.
Er hat Stein im Ultraschall,
haben Sie gesehen, was machen Sie mit den Patienten?
Sie haben keine in der geilen Blase,
das machen Sie jetzt.
Ja, zuerst
würde ich eine Zugang legen.
Haben Sie es schon gemacht?
Zugang ist richtig,
mit Medikamenten ist auch richtig.
Dann würde ich
ja, Infligiöptherapeut,
ich würde eine Antibiotik
veröten
und Antibiotik
gegen Anaryte und Gramm-Negativen,
zum Beispiel
Metronidazole und Cyprofluoxasin,
würde ich veröten
und ja, ich würde auch
ja, ich würde auch
aber er hat kein CRP, was machen Sie?
Geben Sie trotzdem Antibiotik?
Ja, wenn ein...
Entzündungsparameter sind negativ.
Was machen Sie?
Also, ich würde,
ja, wenn ich, der Patient
hat kein Fibar
und wenn alles in Ordnung ist,
dann würde ich,
ja, ich würde Nahrung
und Flüssigkeit
und
ich würde warten, ich glaube,
wenn CRP ist,
unabfällig ist und der andere
unabfällig ist.
Antibiotische Therapie, bei der Komplikation.
Geben Sie, geben Sie, obliate
und dann müssten Sie
Abwarten und Füssigkeit geben, abwarten ob die Schmerz und besser werden.
Wenn er kein Entzündungszeichen hat,
muss man kein Antibiotikum geben.
Er hat wahrscheinlich sogar jetzt ein chronisches Gallenstein leiden.
Und was ist die Therapie
von Gallenstein leiden?
Gallenstein, meinen Sie,
ist das eine RCP?
Er hat einen Gallenstein,
er hat eine Schulistik.
Schulistik, Schulistik.
Was macht man da?
Beim Schulistiatris.
Ja, würde ich Supasmolytikum geben
und dann werde ich warten,
aber wenn ich eine Gallenbilasigstein
feststelle,
würde ich
operative Entfernung empfehlen.
Kann man machen, richtig?
Muss man nicht machen?
Wenn der Patient danach beschwerdet ist,
dann ist er noch jung, er ist 42 Jahre alt.
Er ist 42 Jahre alt, man muss
vielleicht erst mal ihm aufklären und sagen,
die Steine werden nicht von alleine weggehen,
wahrscheinlich nicht.
Die können Entzündungen verursachen
und er muss damit rechnen,
dass er immer wieder diese Beschwerden hat.
Und im Verlauf kann man überlegen,
ob man eine Operation empfiehlt.
Nicht jeder, der einen Gallenstein leiden hat,
muss sofort operiert werden.
Wenn er eine Patient 100 Steine in der Gallenblase hat,
dann kann man es immer noch machen.
Man muss ihn nicht sofort operieren.
Er hat das jetzt akut,
er hat akut Steineleiden
und die haben sich bewegt, die Steine,
die haben diese Schmerzen verursacht
und deswegen hat er jetzt Beschwerden.
Er kann ja auch 2 Jahre lang ohne Schmerzen sein.
Dann kommt er irgendwann wieder.
Richtig? Ja, sie haben den.
Man kann eigentlich hier,
sollte man ihm Schmerzmedikamente geben,
Spaß Moritika empfehlen,
zum Beispiel, weil ich nicht nur wollte,
ich muss gefahren oder wenn er sehr stark Herzschmerzen hat,
kann man natürlich auch, falls ich nicht Morphine geben
oder Petidine geben, Dolantin geben,
so was in der Art, damit er schmerzfrei bleibt.
Und wenn er unbedingt sagt,
ich möchte operiert werden, dann kann man das planen.
Aber es ist keine akut Operation.
Man muss das nicht sofort morgen machen.
Man kann das in 2 Wochen machen. Richtig? Ja.
Wenn er passiert, aber eine tolle dochöle Thürses hat,
eine tolle dochöle Thürses,
dann ist der Stein im Gallengang
oder sollte man eine RCP machen
und den Stein rauszuholen? Ja.
Hab ich alles richtig gesagt?
Ja, ich glaube, jemand hat geschrieben,
außer Morphine, ich glaube,
er hat erwähnt,
hier, wo die Morphine kann,
oder es fängt, kontaktieren
und so, ja, in der Türkei geben wir nicht Morphine.
Also, wir geben schon hier,
ob ihr euch das durch Petidine, Dolantin zum Beispiel.
Ja, Morphine kann die Odysfilter kontaktieren,
so geben wir nicht.
Wie in Deutschland geben das schon, mit Buscopan zusammen,
Novalginen, so was in der Art, das geben wir schon.
Meistens ist das ganz wirksam.
Ja, vielen Dank.
Er sollte Fritzigkeit bekommen
und da muss man gucken, dass er gegebenfalls
Gewicht verliert, so gut es geht,
Ernährungsumstellung, so etwas in der Art machen.
Aber irgendwann, wenn die Beschwerden weiter auftreten sollten
und es chronische Schmerzen werden,
also ein chronisches Gallen-Stein leiden,
dann muss man ihm empfehlen, sich operieren zu lassen.
Vielen Dank.
Gibt es sonst Fragen, habe ich irgendwas vergessen
oder hat irgendetwas, was alt war?
Herr Kollege, wir müssen in der FSP
viele Fachbegriff nennen.
Und deswegen, zum Beispiel Prandial,
Postprandial, Intensiv, Empirisch,
Prokredienter, Persistieren der.
Ja.
Und das ist das, das wir uns hier machen,
dass wir uns in der Art machen.
Das ist eher supportive Therapie.
Ein Beispiel, Adokratischmerz-Terapie.
Adikvatischmerz-Terapie.
Ja.
Be do itut el ma armut et aba krandiel bedoytut indemessim.
Aba ales.
Postkrandiel verebesa. Ok. Filinden karlin.
Postkrandiel, ganz klar.
Intensi, zum Beispiel, invasive, we are noninvasive,
ein Griff bettet, durchführen.
Pülfeld ist oiskanisch.
Das ist eher eine konservative Therapie.
Konservativ-supportive Therapie der iskellen Steinleidens.
Man muss nicht immer Antibiotikum geben, Herr Elit.
Man muss es nicht machen. Nur wenn er in einer Zündung hat, dann ja.
Damit man eine Scholengitis, Scholezyptitis behandeln kann.
Danke schön. Noch an der Frage, Kollegen.
Gibt es Steinlösende-Medikamente?
Es gibt keine richtigen Steinlösende-Medikamente.
Man kann manchmal versuchen. Osofalk, Osodessor,
soll schon säure, heißt das, glaube ich.
Man kann versuchen zu geben. Manchmal hilft das gut.
Ich habe einige Patienten, die ich damit behandle, die immer wieder
Grieß bilden. Keine Stein, aber Grieß.
Sie werden immer wieder Bilder, die Schmerzen machen.
Mit diesem Osofalk, sag ich mal, kann man einmal am Tag,
dann grießt das besser ab und die Patienten weniger beschwerden.
So kann man Osofalk erwähnen bei der Prüfung.
Es ist keine richtige Therapie. Eigentlich nicht.
Eigentlich nicht. Das ist eher so second sein.
Also, 2. Technotherapie, wenn Sie keine Erfolge haben mit Novalgin oder so,
weiß ich was. Und die Patienten immer wieder, die sie beschwerzen,
aber da kann man sagen, Herr Maus, wir probieren mal das
und das einmal am Tag nehmen. Probieren Sie das mal aus, ob das Ihnen hilft
oder nicht. Kann man probieren. Aber es gibt, glaube ich, auch hier,
Sie sind doch, machen doch Akkupunktur und so was.
Da gibt es auch pflanzliche Therapie oder so was, das man geben kann.
Es gibt eine Medikamente, der Rohahol, Rohahol heißt.
Kleine